hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one distinction connected with a
set of terms that is associated with
Emmanuel Kant that we find coming up in
his proma to any future metaphysics
particularly in part two of the work is
that between phenomena and numina and
it's in his view not a radically new
distinction it's one that as he says uh
since the oldest days of philosophy
inquirers into pure reason have thought
that and then he goes on so this is
something that goes all the way back and
you know if you know your history of
philosophy you can say aha
this begins perhaps with Parmenides or
Plato or somebody else along the way
right and it it's it's one that hasn't
gone away I would say in part because
Kant himself uses it and Kant is not
saying that there is no such thing as
numina it's all just phenomenal but he
is going to set some limits and he's
going to carry out a kind of interesting
reversal in certain respects so he tells
us that these inquirers into pure reason
have thought that besides the things of
sense the sin
zenin or the appearances
theirin right a term that we've
encountered earlier in the work there
were certain beings of the understanding
uh Numa which should constitute an
intelligible world and the German for
beings of understanding FIS vasin so you
know beings things there's not a radical
difference here they're both vasin which
can mean thing can mean Essence um here
the main distinction that we're
interested in is that between what is
phenomenal or presented to us as
phenomena and then what we are thinking
is out there as num or
Numa and he says that that they made a
mistake right as appearance and illusion
were by those men identified a mistake
we may well excuse in an undeveloped
Epoch so illusion shine is identified
with right they're mixing these things
up not distinguishing them actuality VI
click kite winds up being ascribed to
the Numa and you know if you know Plato
or you know some other philosophers who
are espousing similar points of view the
distinction between appearance which is
a losery not really what the things are
and then the reality of the thing and
this carries forward all the way into
the modern period we could talk about
you know somebody like John Lock and
talking about substance and you know
primary and secondary qualities all of
this sort of thing falls under these
there's something that's really real and
something that we take as being real
because it appears to us it's closer to
us closer to the ways in which we're
typically apprehending things through
the senses and that's the phenomena and
so he says we indeed rightly considering
objects of sense AOS mere appearances
mere Shin right also uses the term
repres presentations at different point
saying yeah that things of the senses
things that we perceive are just
appearances that that's fine we don't
have to say that they have absolute
reality in and of themselves um he says
we confess that they are they are based
upon a thing in itself right soing anels
that's the thing in
itself Li So at their basis at their
Foundation at their ground lies the
thing in itself a little bit more
metaphorical language there rather but
even saying something is based on
something else is using spatial
metaphors now Kant goes on and he says
that um we know not this thing as it is
in itself we we don't know things in
themselves as things in themselves
doesn't mean we don't have any possible
way of talking about it or grasping it
but we don't we don't know them we can't
cognize them the way we can things that
we encounter in our experience the
things that are appearances and we know
the thing in itself through its
appearances through the appearances that
we say are in some way connected with it
and what does this mean the way in which
our senses are affected by this unknown
something he goes on and he says the
understanding therefore by assuming
appearances by saying that appearances
actually do exist we encounter them
right the phenomena happen we sense them
we encounter them we talk about them we
make judge judgments about them uh
because of that we can say that we Grant
also the existence of things in
themselves and thus far we may say the
repres
representation of such things as are the
basis of appearances what does he mean
by that things in themselves numina the
basis that they are providing uh the
representation of these uh consequently
of mere beings of the understanding is
not only he says admissible so not only
can we talk about them but
unavoidable wouldn't Fair mildly
we can't get out of talking about them
so you know sometimes I should pause
here for a moment there are misconstrues
of Kant that you're going to find out
there you know in textbooks in the
internet land all over the place maybe
somebody that you know who thinks that
they know about Kant and they'll say you
know Kant reduced everything to the
merely phenomenal he took the reality of
things
away no he didn't he just says we can't
know the reality of those things the
Numa the way that we know the phenomena
but in fact Kant thinks that there are
Numa out there and they are what
phenomena are ultimately based upon we
just can't have
experiences of the numina the way we not
only can but constantly do of the
phenomena so this is a a pretty
important uh thing distress about how
people get this section of K's work
wrong and attribute to him all sorts of
views that he doesn't have essentially
making what we call a straw man fallacy
and then they get very upset oh K is
barrowing our way to knowing anything no
he's not he's just saying whatever
you're going to know you're going to
encounter in experience as a phenomena
right doesn't mean you can't think about
the numina but you got to realize that
it's a numa not a phenomenon so he goes
on and he says our critical deduction by
no mean excludes things of that sort
what things of that sort numina but
limits the principles the gunet of the
aesthetic in such a way that they won't
extend to all things because if you did
then everything would be turned into
mere air shinung or appearance but that
they hold good only of objects of
possible experience so you know thinks
that's perfectly fine so he says thing
beings of the understanding are admitted
but with the inculcation of this rule
which admits no
exception we neither know nor can know
now notice this
qualifier anything determinate whatever
about these pure beings of the
understanding because our Pure concepts
of the understanding as well as our Pure
intuitions extend to nothing but objects
of possible experience phenomena not to
Numa now he's not saying here because of
the qualifier you can't know anything at
all about the Numa we
can they exist they have reality can't
thingss right they are the basis they're
at the ground of the phenomena that's
knowing something isn't it it's just not
knowing anything
determinate about this new
right or numina in general so very
important distinction to to call out of
the text there and he goes on and he
says this is in section 33 there's a a
Temptation a seduction a mistake that
people tend to make he says there's
something seductive in our Pure concepts
of the understanding they're so cool we
could say that tempts us to a
Transcendent use transcendent meaning
going Beyond going beyond what the
boundaries of possible experience or the
limits the grza of possible experience
and so he says what are some examples of
this we've already been talking about
this in this section substance right and
then he brings up several others that
are really quite
interesting
so power craft right he hasn't talked
about that this much at this point but
you know remember back to if you've ever
read hume's inquiry or treaties that our
notion of power is based on the notion
of causality so he's bringing up quality
here and then he'll talk about reality
realit right as opposed to Vite here um
so or or existence da right or existence
so the reality of of something uh
perhaps of a whole maybe he's
referencing here here the you know the
substance cause and Community but
there's a a fourth one in here that's
very interesting action and the word for
Action here is hlong now that we can
also translate as comportment that is
action in the sense of like Human Action
doing things so this has a practical
scope here as well something that we
would find
handled in the critique of practical
reason and later on that's also a later
critique in the groundwork for the
metaphysics and morals where we're going
to see a similar discussion of you know
can we get to things in themselves and
what what freedom is and all of that
sort of stuff so these are Concepts you
know bin uh and um action is included in
those and then there's a and the others
un right right Etc we would say so he
tells us that with
these they seem to be quite independent
of experience containing nothing of
sense appearance and so they're
apparently applicable they seem we might
actually play on words here you know
they appear right they uh they elus
illusorily uh show us that they are
applicable to things in themselves
and he says what strengthens this
conjecture they contain a necessity of
determination in themselves which
experience never attains so he brings up
cause here again the concept of cause
contains a rule According to which one
state follows another now here's the key
term
necessarily but experience can only show
us one state of things often or at most
commonly follows another so it doesn't
give us strict universality nor
necessity so Kant is saying you know the
pure concept of the understanding which
do give us necessity
uh you know objective validity uh
universality that's why we're tempted to
go and say yeah these are Numa these are
uh about the Numa we're getting at them
and he says no that's not what's
actually happening so he goes on and
says concepts of the understanding seem
to have a deeper meaning and content
than can be exhausted by their merely
empirical use so the understanding
inadvertently adds for itself to the
house House of experience a much more
extensive wing it goes from looking at
the phenomena and what we can say about
them and the understanding that is uh we
can say conditioning our experience of
that to extending a whole illusory
imaginary wing of numina to the house a
very interesting metaphor that he's
using there and we could say you know
what are we talking about there what
he's earlier called the intelligible
world right the world of the
understanding um a little bit later he's
going to talk about um these uh the the
here we go the numina together with
their sum total the intelligible World
um he's going that's the the the wing of
the house that he's bringing up there we
don't really know enough about numina
and we can never know enough about
numina to do that sort of thing that
were so easily seduced into doing and
people have been in the past including
prime example Plato with his
intelligible World which is the more
real world about which we can know more
than we can about the world of
appearances the world of deceptive sense
knowledge right so Kant is not saying no
numina he's just saying numina are not
within the the realm of possible
experience so it's really the phenomena
that we have to look to if we want to
see how the pure concepts of the
understanding do in fact
apply